that happens at the same time like a bug
does a game oh my god it's filled its
full so hard it's so hard it's so hard
oh that's not good okay oh god oh god
sack of crap he said a biscuit Oh God
Christmas golly gee gosh where'd he go
Frick so there was okay all right
randomize because if it was open and I
could see what's inside then I'd be
talking what the hell okay never mind
then
I got him out of the window what
happened
why was he cloning [ __ ] you okay
cool I have that now you dickbag
you mean the blow okay the King likes
drawing who's the King oh oh do I go
down why'd you stop go
I guess I lost oh god oh my brain wants
to say bull like I know what we do oh
God
I mean there is something to enjoy about
this book Oh God it seems like they're
doing some weird experiments on these
kids I'm dead I'm dead okay Oh
who's with the honking oh boy but I
suspect that there might be some deadly
creatures in the geunji you can use
thanks for watching all of the videos in
this compilation are available in the
description so check them out and if
you'd like to see more in the future
please leave a like to let me know if
you enjoyed this video and you'd like to
see more on a daily basis please
subscribe today or if you're already
subscribed share this video with a
thread
thanks again for watching and I'll see
you in the next video bye bye